all right people this is it last promo
before i head out on tour the don't burn
this country book tour is starting april
19th in west palm beach with my buddy
donald trump jr then we're heading over
to clearwater florida with benny johnson
we are going to raleigh north carolina
with the daily wires andrew clavin we're
going to be in atlanta with the willy
wonka of politics michael malus we're
going to be in chicago with the
effervescent janmi park we're going to
be in dallas with glenn beck of the
blaze megan mccain will be joining me in
washington d.c right in the heart of the
swamp megan kelly will be joining me in
west nyack new york dennis prager in
brea california larry elder in oxnard
california douglas murray in san jose
california blake masters and charlie
kirk in phoenix arizona and brian callan
will be bringing up the rear in denver
colorado you can get tickets right now
at daverubin.com
events we've got vip tickets we've got
general admission tickets if you want
the hug if you want the photo we give a
little extra talk during the vip thing i
can't wait to get out there and see you
guys and say hi different show every
night it'll be fun it'll be heartfelt
it'll be deep it'll be political and
apolitical it will be a little bit of
everything i hope to see you guys out
there again it's daverubin.com
events and we kick this thing off on
april 19th right here in west palm beach
in the free state of florida
[Music]
you